we have an opportunity today to condemn  or condone birtherism is racist saying a  Mexican judge can't be fair because of  his heritage is racist saying immigrants  from Mexico are rapists is racist saying  there were good people on both sides in  charlottesville is racist calling  African countries countries is racist  and telling four members of this body to  go home is racist and then Muslims do  you think it's not racist at this point  of order do you think it's not the  gentleman was suspended gentlemen is  that what you're saying right now mr.  Collins mr. Collins the gentleman from  California is out of order  the gentleman from Georgia gentleman  from California shall suspend